oh my gosh since turning 40 I am just
like taking everything in so much more
than I was in my 20s so I want to
want to face I want to know the like
love and friendliness in this room it's
so funny too because I hear that you are
an incredibly determined person and I've
known you a little bit over the years
and we have a connection which we'll get
into
um but you don't give up on things right
like I go to horseback riding like
what's the story that can be I think a
really good thing like that served me
very well when it when it's come to my
career for sure obviously there's like a
pretty
um now famous Blue Crush story like that
really set my career off but I think it
can also be this is something I learned
throughout my 30s and turning 40 is the
importance as well of letting go
and um you know because we've both gone
through divorces yes and that was the
big lesson for me which was
um we're just gonna Jump Right In we had
a whole plan it's out the window
my kind of conversation I know I was
like let's do it um I I think that like
for someone who really doesn't want to
fail at things and who wants to like be
so determined and um you know
disciplined and you know the idea of
failing a marriage was so heartbreaking
like it just oh I it's still hard it's
still hard to think about
um but ultimately it that experience the
process of understanding that um
to me it became not a failure but it
became the completion of a chapter and
understanding that that's really what
life is if life this is going to sound
very esoteric but if life is the book
it's like how beautiful to have chapters
how beautiful to have pages and so I'm
I'm really grateful for that and how do
you let go because again like I'm
learning that I I have held on White
Knuckle monkey grip tight yeah so much
in my life there's a very famous
um Buddha saying actually that says one
grips the tightest before letting go
which I found to be quite helpful to me
and I know that having sort of been very
aligned in the past with like a very A
type personality and really like kind of
control like finding a lot I wrote this
in my 40th letter to myself was you know
you were more comfortable with control
than you were with
um you know more comfortable with
structure than you were with just sort
of letting go of things and I'll tell
you I'm a lot happier letting go my one
of my new favorite things is saying like
oh that's not my problem do you know
Glennon Doyle yes yes I'm worse I'm
tamed yes and her parents has everything
me too so that was that was a really
viable for me like
um going through my doors I don't know
if
I I mean divorced before that book yeah
I've been married three times
that's why I'm like I gotta either be
like Liz Taylor and just keep going and
be awesome or I gotta call it for the
rest of my life and I think there's so
many lessons in each one I'm sure it's
like why does it break us women so much
to fail in a relationship that d word
equals oh I can't I I know I know the
feeling of of you know I look I don't
think anyone goes into a marriage and
and think that it's going to be
temporary like I certainly didn't I
didn't even that wasn't even an option
um you and I have a very similar
um like Quest
to align ourselves with the courage that
it takes to be vulnerable I think like I
certainly see that in you and your show
really I have to give you a little story
um when I was flying out here yesterday
from Los Angeles
um I was carrying my little outfit on
the plane in a garment bag and this
really really sweet lady her name is
Angela
um she said is that a wedding dress and
I said oh no no but it's a very special
outfit and she said what's the outfit
for and I said oh well I'm an actress
and I'm going on the Drew Barrymore show
tomorrow and she's like oh I love Drew
Barrymore she's like she's she's just
the best she's so sweet she brings so
much love and so much joy into the world
and I said I will tell her oh
my God but you can't you know
I think that kind of Inner Glow like
that shine like you give so many people
um you know just for me like meeting
someone it was such a genuine reaction I
wish you could have seen it so
um we have a very important person in
common
um my very dear old friend Justin Long a
boyfriend uh a dear friend and he and
Kate have found each other in this world
and become this incredibly joyous bonded
real deal
you know holding hands like the ultimate
couple you root for oh thank you
oh that's so sweet he loves you so much
he just loves you so so deeply so when
we wanted to premiere season three I
like to do it with personal
relationships and friends and I asked
Justin if he would come on the show and
what was your response I was with him
when he got the um ask and he's like oh
Drew wants me to go on her show and I
said oh you have to do it
[Applause]
and yeah I was so excited I was so
excited because I knew there's so much
love between the two of you and
um so much yes fun and like a wild
um I always say you guys were like in
the tornado together yes right yeah yeah
it's like it's the time in your life
where you're just like I want to like
feel I want to do everything I want to
you know just like be a part of the
adventure in like a wild way which is so
much fun
um and he just he just loves you so much
and I um
I look I grew up with a family who my
mom was married once before my aunt
um was married before and our
Christmases you know big celebrations
are spent with like ex-husbands coming
to the Celebration still we have
pictures up of ex-husbands in the house
and like so I was
um I was truly brought up with this idea
that yes the love might occupy another
space of the heart but it doesn't go
away and I think it's so important to
promote that and to talk about it and to
like really believe that
you know in asking him to come on
because of your answer I asked him if we
could also be open about your
relationship and talk about how we
celebrate our exes yeah and because of
your upbringing because of who you are
we were able to celebrate your
relationship talk about we as women
actually have an opportunity we have a
choice of how we can navigate our
partners that we're currently with with
confidence and blessing and uh uh a
sharing goodness that makes all women
look good and rise and it just was the
high road and I'm like Justin move over
it's all about Kate now I feel like the
love like
um to me like the heart can expand you
know what I mean it's like I feel like
if you really lean into the
expansiveness of love and that includes
friendships
um
it's it's only it's only for the better
like any time I've closed my heart down
because of ego or whatever it's it
hasn't made me feel good and I like I
want to move to the warmth you know I
want to stay in the warmth she sent me
flowers after I got home to flowers with
a card by her and then immediately took
a video of myself receiving the flowers
because I wanted to keep the narrative
going of how we can champion each other
yeah and how this would be the idyllic
Utopia in which we can live
and that is why you are one of my
behavioral Heroes and you're mine
Angela you are here with us
[Music]